A warm welcome to you, the listener.
We are stepping into a really profound text today.
We're doing a deep dive into the treatise, Establishing the I Am a Mite by the author, Enesa Buri.
And you know, the way he constructs his argument here is, it's actually pretty incredible.
It really is.
To give you a quick preview of what we're looking at, he basically walks nature's house specimen by specimen to prove one claim.
Yeah, and that claim is, and we'll be coming back to this,
Every ordered thing has a summit.
The human being is nature's and the IMAM is humanity's.
Exactly.
And that single claim, I mean, it requires us to look at the physical world through an entirely different lens than we're used to.
Yeah, because on the surface, when we examine a flame or a grain of wheat or red stone, we are dealing with chemistry.
Mineralogy, yeah.
Exactly.
So the immediate puzzle for anyone encountering this framework for the first time is pretty obvious.
I mean, why should facts about the physical earth, like about how a plant grows or how a metal melts, have anything whatsoever to say about human authority?
Yeah, why should creation itself be called to the witness stand, basically, to testify about who should lead a religious community?
It is the essential question to begin with, I think, because this is not
It's not a casual tour through a botanical garden just to admire the scenery.
We are engaging with the classical Ismaili reading of the cosmos here.
Yeah.
In this framework, the physical world is not just a collection of random disconnected facts.
No, it's a tightly built argument.
It is a trial where nature literally gives sworn testimony.
And the whole argument rests on the premise that things in this world are not equal.
You know, they aren't flat.
They naturally refine themselves into hierarchies of, well, better and dust.
So the author is laying out a ladder and he kind of demands that we climb it step by step.
Yeah, he moves us from the raw elements up to the stars, down into the earth for metals and jewels, into the fields, through the animal kingdom before finally arriving at the human being.
And this natural witness stands firmly alongside the revealed law.
I mean, the treatise has already established the office of leadership as the pole and foundation of religion, the center without which the whole structure just...
It just falls apart.
Exactly.
So the turn to nature is meant to corroborate that absolute necessity, proving that the spiritual world and the physical world operate on the exact same architecture.
So to start proving this architecture, he begins at the absolute bedrock, the four elements.
The ancients recognized earth, air, water, and fire as the raw materials of the physical world, the archaean.
The pillars, yeah, from which every single composite body is assembled.
And among these four pillars, he places fire at the undisputed top.
stands at a height like no other element can reach.
But we should pause here to understand the mechanical reasoning.
Like why is fire elevated above cold, dryness, and humidity?
Well, in the ancient physical worldview, those other three qualities are fundamentally receptive.
I mean, they take on conditions.
Yeah.
Earth can be moved.
Water can be shaped.
Air can be compressed.
But fire is entirely different.
Because fire acts.
It acts.
It gives off light, it causes upward motion, it lifts, it rises, and crucially, it keeps the other three elements quickened.
Without the intervention of fire, the other elements just lapse into complete stagnant inertness.
Which establishes A crucial foundational criterion for, well, everything we're going to explore today.
A domain is never crowned by the member that is most acted upon.
The summit is always the one that gives.
The summit is the originator, the quickener.
Just as fire illumines and elevates the material world, pulling it out of inertness, the highest religious pillar of the age illumines the spiritual world.
The summit of the elements and the summit of the human world are performing the exact same function.
One operates in matter and the other operates in the spirit.
The author then introduces the historical figure of Abraham to anchor this idea.
Yeah, he suggests that this hidden meaning, this concept of a summit that quickens and illuminates, was the real reason Abraham once commanded his people to glorify the fire and strictly forbade them from ever letting it die.
I mean, I can anticipate a counterargument here.
Let's steelman the fire worshipers for a second.
If you are an ancient person and you witness the raw, life-giving power of fire, it makes total sense to revere it.
Oh, absolutely.
You are freezing in the cold and fire gives you heat.
You are blind in the dark, fire gives you sight.
Vulnerable to predators, fire offers a shield.
Observing that raw physical power, the literal flame itself seems entirely worthy of literal reverence.
But that is precisely the trap those early communities fell into.
They grasped the symbol because I mean the symbol is undeniably powerful, but they entirely missed the reality it was pointing toward.
They built a whole cult around the maintenance of an actual physical fire, like feeding logs into a pit.
And the author's rebuttal is that Abraham was pointing past the physical flame.
He was pointing to the unextinguishable light of guidance.
The instruction was never about wood and sparks.
No, it was about preserving the continuous presence of the true guide.
And the text seals this with scripture, turning imamate of an unextinguishable light directly onto the historical enemies who try to falsely claim its place or try to destroy it.
The would-be extinguishers try to put out God's light with their mouths.
They attempt to blow out the flame through force.
through propaganda.
But scripture declares God will not allow it until he perfects his light, even if the unbelievers detest it.
So the enemies who attempt to extinguish this light are merely fulfilling scripture.
They are proving the incorruptibility of the true summit by failing to destroy it.
Which is such a powerful image.
It is.
So from the foundational elements on earth, the author demands we lift our gaze to the heavens.
Among all the wandering lights and spheres in the sky, he singles out the sun.
The planets have their gradations, obviously, their varying speeds and influences, but the sun is the undisputed summit.
Because the physical eye cannot see a single thing without its light, and absolutely nothing grows without its warmth.
No plant, no animal, no newborn child comes to full physical growth outside of the sun's direct influence.
It is the ultimate giver of the heavens.
It mirrors perfectly the role of the religious guide who enlightens human insight and makes souls shine with guidance.
And just as there were fair worshippers who mistook the symbol for the reality, there are sun worshippers.
People who bowed to the physical burning disk in the sky, completely failing to see the spiritual reality it was designed to signify.
The author brings in a fascinating piece of prophecy here, and we need to unpack how he reads it.
He introduces a saying from the Prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family concerning one of the major signs of the end of times.
The prophecy states that the sun will rise in the MGH rib, the west.
This requires careful logical analysis, I think, because we read that prophecy literally, it proposes impossible astronomy.
The author points out that if the physical sun were to swerve from its fixed ordained orbit for even the blink of an eye, the entire physical world would be thrown into chaos.
It would be destroyed.
The gravitational
physical laws holding the earth together would just collapse.
Both reason and the observable laws of nature rule out a literal interpretation of this event.
So because the literal physics are impossible, the event must be read esoterically.
It is not an astronomical catastrophe meant to terrify us.
It is a historical reality.
The sun rising in the West is the true guide rising in the West.
The impossible astronomy transforms into history.
A history that the author notes was actually witnessed by the grace of God when the true leadership manifested itself geographically in the West.
The author continues drawing these concentric circles, showing how every system has a center.
He notes the four most glorious signs of the zodiac and identifies the supreme sign among them, likening it to the highest proofs of the religious mission.
He maps this onto the geography of the Earth itself, identifying the 4th climb, the most temperate, balanced region aligned with the sun as the most.
The religious summit is the most excellent within the human hierarchy, just as the sun and the temperate climes govern the physical world.
The argument then pulls us down from the sky and into the deep earth, looking at what human hands dig out of the ground.
Among all the metals that melt and can be shaped by a hammer, gold is the summit.
The reasoning here connects physical properties with social reality, which is quite clever.
Yeah, gold is the medium of transaction.
It fixes the value of all other goods.
It settles the dealings of creation.
In the very same way, the religious guide is the standard of intellectual and spiritual substance.
The guide is the one who settles the well-being of people in this world and the next, establishing the true measure of actions.
Gold measures material worth.
The guide measures religious worth.
The argument then moves from base metals to precious stones, and the logic sharpens significantly here.
Among all the jewels pulled from the dark, the sapphire is identified as the finest
And among the various colors of sapphire, the red ruby is crowned as the absolute summit.
The criterion for the red ruby's supremacy is vital to grasp because it shifts our understanding of what makes a summit.
The red ruby is not crowned because it is the most dazzling to the eye or the most rare in the earth or the most expensive in a marketplace.
No, it is crowned for its absolute incorruptibility.
If you throw a red ruby into a blazing fire or plunge it into the crushing depths of water, it retains its essence completely unchanged.
It holds its purity, its radiance, and its physical weight under total assault.
I don't buy that yet a ruby surviving fire is chemistry, not human authority.
I mean, it demonstrates a high melting point and incredibly dense
crystalline stability.
Why should the physical property of a stone dictate anything about the necessity or the nature of human authority?
Well, the rebuttal to that friction lies in understanding what the natural symbol is doing in a world of constant opposition.
The author is cataloging the nature of endurance under assault.
Think about the stones the ruby defeats, the emerald, the diamond, the turquoise, the jade.
Each of these stones is prized by kings.
Each is beautiful, yet each is fundamentally vulnerable.
Under extreme heat or pressure, they shatter, they discolor, they melt, they lose their defining characteristics.
Only the red ruby comes through the trials of fire and water entirely whole, its identity perfectly intact.
So the argument is asserting that the true
summit must be incorruptible.
In a world full of pressures, shifting politics, and forces that spoil and compromise lesser leaders, the red ruby is the natural image of an authority that cannot be corrupted.
It is a portrait of an embattled ruler.
The natural world is demonstrating that external pressure, no matter how severe, does not change the essential nature of the true summit.
And the author anticipates the objection that these might just be neat numerical matches, like finding 7 jewels to correspond to 7 historical figures.
He allows that surface reading, but insists the deeper argument is about degrees of excellence.
Because the natural symbols, the elements, the stars, the ruby, are permanently present in every single age,
The reality they symbolize must also be permanently present.
The permanent existence of the ruby in the earth proves the permanent necessity of the incorruptible guide in the world.
Leaving the deep earth, the author takes us up into the light, into the farmer's field and the orchard.
He observes the grains that nourish human beings, placing wheat at the summit.
Wheat is the most balanced.
It best builds and sustains the physical body.
In the same way, human souls draw their life, their structure, and their knowledge from their proper spiritual summit.
From the field, he steps into the orchard and the imagery becomes incredibly specific.
The summit of all fruit-bearing trees is the date palm.
The reasons for this are profound, really, because the date palm uniquely mirrors the physical and biological reality of the human being.
The anatomy and life cycle of the palm are fascinating.
Unlike most trees, it exists strictly as male and female entities.
It requires active fertilization to bear fruit, much like animal reproduction.
Furthermore, nothing of the date palm is ever wasted.
Every single part of the tree is utilized by humanity, and its fruit provides nourishment in every conceivable condition.
Raw, dried, cooked.
The text even ventures into the realm of the dreaming mind.
If a person dreams of plucking baits from a palm, the classical interpretation signifies receiving a direct benefit from a believer.
And at the ultimate highest level, that points to the head of all believers.
The tree resembles the human form.
It wastes absolutely nothing.
It feeds us completely, and it appears in our subconscious as the ultimate figure of benefit.
The author is drawing on a much older, deeply rooted tradition here.
The early compiler recorded a specific riddle posed by the prophet to his companions.
He asked them to identify a tree in the wilderness whose leaves never fall, likening it directly to the faithful human being.
The companions guessed various desert plants but could not identify it.
The prophet finally named the date palm.
It is the perfect natural figure
for the human summit toward which this entire catalog has been climbing.
Which brings us to a critical pivot in the text.
We move from the grains and fruits that merely maintain the healthy body to something far more urgent.
We enter the intense high stakes realm of medicinal plants.
We look at mild medicines that have been refined and perfected to such a staggering degree that they cross a threshold.
They become antidotes, the TYAHQ.
These are the rare, potent healing compounds capable of pulling a person back from the very brink of death.
While wheat maintains health, the antidote performs a rescue.
The physician reaches for the antidote when all milder remedies have failed.
When the venom is already in the bloodstream, it reaches the dying.
This adds an entirely new dimension to the portrait we are building.
The summit is not merely a giver of light like the fire or an incorruptible presence like the ruby.
It is a restorer.
It reaches a soul that has been given up for lost.
The word of the guide serves as the ultimate antidote for souls.
It provides healing from spiritual death, from the illness of ignorance, from paralyzing doubt, and from the vicious discord that fractures human communities.
The soul, dying of doubt, is violently rescued by the guide
just as the dying physical body is rescued by the chemical antidote.
At this critical juncture, seeing the vast scale of this natural hierarchy, seeing the necessity of the rescue, we must restate the core thesis that anchors every single observation we've made.
Every ordered thing has a summit.
The human being is nature's, and the I'm am is humanity's.
With that restorative image established, the author abruptly turns the picture dark.
The argument requires a shadow.
If the true guides are the healing medicines, the potent antidotes, then we must confront the existence of poisons.
The usurpers who seize the place of the true guides by force, who demand obedience without possessing the true light, are likened to the deadly poisons and harmful substances that grow wild in the earth.
The charge against the usurpers isn't a separate isolated attack.
I mean, it rides entirely inside the imagery.
These toxic plants are fatal to whoever listens to them keeps their company or leans toward them.
They destroy the souls of those who trust them unless the true antidote reaches the victim first.
And the usurpers are not just poisons.
The author likens them to useless, worthless stones.
They are the rubble destined for the fire.
They serve no structural purpose in the building of a community.
The text angers this terrifying image in scripture, referencing the pebble-covered hell and the fire whose fuel is people and stones.
The enemies, the usurpers, are gathered into the imagery of worthless rubble and consuming fire.
The single
image of the medicinal plant splits cleanly into two opposing faces.
The cure that saves and the poison that kills.
The author elaborates on this dark mirror by examining the literalists, the AHL as ZAH here.
These are the leaders who cling only to the outer husk of religion, memorizing the rules but entirely missing the healing inner sense of the law.
The text likens them to plants that are bitter, foul, and covered in defensive thorns.
They wound anyone who tries to come near them and they yield absolutely no fruit.
That sounds like wordplay relabeling nature as signs.
So it means whatever you need.
If you want to praise your leader, you call him a sweet fruit.
If you want to attack your political enemy, you call him a bitter thorn.
How is this a binding philosophical argument rather than just convenient poetic name-calling?
The author's rebuttal to that friction is to ground the imagery directly in the ultimate authority of scripture, demonstrating that the Quran itself codes the natural world exactly this way.
It isn't a human invention.
A good word is explicitly described in the text as a good tree with deeply set roots and branches reaching the heavens, giving fruit in every single season.
Conversely, a bad word is described as a bad tree, violently torn up from the surface of the earth, completely lacking any stability, footing, or nourishment.
In this philosophical framework is not a neutral, silent backdrop.
It actively sorts the true guide from the false.
The most immediate of our physical senses, our taste and our smell, are called to the witness stand to testify.
Sweet, delicious, nourishing plants that captivate the human soul and delight the eye represent the speech and the knowledge of the true guides.
The body's natural gravitation towards sweet nourishment is proof of the soul's natural gravitation toward truth.
Meanwhile, the putrid, repellent plants who stench
sickens the stomach rather than heals the body stand for the leaders of error.
What the true summit offers is fragrant and healing.
What the counterfeit offers is bitter, foul, and fatal.
The involuntary physical responses of taste and smell are woven directly into the fabric of the theological argument.
The survey then leaves the rooted plants and moves into the dynamic animal kingdom, where the pattern of summits reasserts itself in its most plain, undeniable, and aggressive form.
We look at the horse, the eagle, and the lion.
Each of these creatures sits at the absolute top of its kind through sheer physical superiority in a specific trait.
The horse is the summit of swiftness, utility, and tireless service in battle.
The eagle holds undisputed, absolute mastery of the air seeing what lesser birds cannot see.
The lion possesses total, terrifying mastery of the hunt.
They prove that every genus naturally, inevitably arranges itself around its highest, most dominant member.
But the author does not stop at creatures that merely dominate their domain through force or speed.
Dominance is not the ultimate peak of nature.
He quietly escalates the argument.
He moves from animals that possess superior traits
to animals that are fundamentally generous.
He looks for creatures that yield a benefit the world could not otherwise possess.
This carries the argument all the way back to the very first criterion established by fire.
The true summit is always a giver.
Among the animals, the gazelle and the bee give the most profound gifts.
The gazelle surrenders its musk, a precious, enduring fragrance used in medicines and perfumes.
And the bee yields its honey, a substance of pure nourishment, preservation, and healing.
The animal survey bends intentionally toward the specific kind of summit the entire treatise is advocating for.
It is not advocating for a lion that merely consumes its prey.
It is advocating for a summit whose excellence overflows
into tangible, life-saving benefit for others.
Within the highly complex structure of the hive, the text finds its most powerful animal emblem.
The author focuses intently on the bee following its chief.
It's Ya-S-O-B.
This is the lead bee, the central authority around which the entire hive meticulously orders its existence, its defense, and its production.
The terminology chosen here is incredibly specific and deeply intentional.
The author points out that the prophet specifically used this exact word when addressing the commander of the faithful, peace be upon him.
He explicitly named him the chief of the believers, using the very term applied to the leader of the hive.
The lead bee of the hive becomes the perfect natural mirror for the father of imams.
The hive orders itself around its chief for one purpose, to produce out of its own body a cure for human beings.
The text cites scripture regarding the bee, noting that from its bellies comes a drink of varying colors containing healing for mankind.
The entire natural survey of potent antidotes, sweet plants, and generous animals circles this single historical figure, a guide whose word operates as absolute medicine for the community.
This brings us to the final sweeping resolution of the latter.
All the creation has been surveyed, from the fire to the ruby, from the palm to the hive.
The text now states plainly that humankind is the ultimate, undisputed summit of all these realms combined.
Everything created before the human being, the raw elements, the precious minerals, the sustaining plants, the animals,
ultimately has its hidden advantage returned to us.
The merits of the entire physical cosmos are gathered up, synthesized, and made to appear in the human being.
The author grounds this grand philosophical claim in the stark daily reality of what human beings actually do.
We do not merely exist passively within nature, hoping to survive it.
We read nature and we command it.
We harness water
drawing it from deep valleys through complex irrigation to force dry land to yield crops.
We strike flint to command fire, turning the most volatile element into our servant.
We crossbreed animals that would never naturally mate in the wild.
We graft branches from different trees to yield fruits the world has never seen before.
We mine deep into the earth to extract jewels from hidden mineral scenes.
Left entirely to themselves, none of these raw materials would ever fully manifest their hidden worth.
The ruby would sit in the dark.
The water would pool in the valley.
The excellence of creation would remain buried and useless.
The human being is the creature at which everything below is perfected, forced into its highest utility and set in order.
Quotes a beautiful piece of poetry to capture this vast enfoldment.
He quotes the father of imams, asking the reader, do you reckon yourself a small thing when within you the greater world lies enfolded?
What that poetry asserts in a single line, the author has spent the entire exhaustive catalog proving.
Domain by domain, he has demonstrated exactly how the greater world, the heat of the fire, the endurance of the stone, the generosity of the bee is gathered into the one creature capable of reading it all.
But here we must push back on the premise.
Are humans truly the summit?
Or are we just another animal near the top of the food chain that happens to have a clever trick?
The horse is significantly faster than a human.
The eagle possesses eyesight that reaches far beyond our biological capabilities.
The lion is vastly stronger.
Why does our ability to manipulate tools and harness water make us a cosmic summit rather than just an unusually intelligent ape?
The counter to that lies in the specific, transformative nature of our reason.
An eagle can see a fish from high above, but an eagle cannot take the raw materials of the earth and build an aqueduct.
A lion can kill a gazelle, but a lion cannot extract the musk to create medicine.
Reason allows the human being to redirect the very course of rivers and force barren ground to bear life.
Without the human intellect to extract, combine, measure, and cultivate, the soil's richness and the seam's buried gem would remain forever latent.
Reason is the precise, unique faculty that makes the hidden worth of creation appear.
But that exact same faculty of reason carries terrifying existential stakes.
Because reason allows us to manipulate and transform our environment, it is also the faculty that, if left ungoverned by a higher guide, becomes an instrument of absolute catastrophic ruin.
This is the hinge of the entire treatise.
This is the crisis the text has been building toward.
Just as the benefit of all lower creation flows upward to humanity, the benefit of all humanity must flow upward to its own summit.
When faced with this logic, you have to concede the terrifying reality of the argument.
I mean, if reason makes us the peak of nature, that very same reason, without the first imam or the guides of any subsequent age to stir the intellect to life and set its measure, makes the human being vastly worse than cattle.
An animal, left entirely to its own devices, does not scheme its own corruption.
An animal has its specific uses and operates safely within its instinctual boundaries.
A lion kills to eat, not to conquer.
But a human being who refuses the training of virtue, who operates solely on brilliant, ungoverned reason, is wholly given over to evil.
The human without a guide is not just a lesser human.
They become the architect of a ruin, a scale of destruction that no beast could ever imagine or execute.
This is why the entire cosmic ladder lands not on a feeling of pleasant
for nature, but on a strict, unavoidable duty.
The cosmos is not an abstraction to be merely observed.
It terminates in an obligation.
Humanity was created to acquire virtues and knowledge.
That acquisition strictly requires receiving direction from the true guides.
If human excellence were never made manifest through this guidance, then the worth of the plants, the animals and the elements would never be truly known either.
There would be absolutely no wisdom in the creation of any of it.
The entire universe would be a pointless exercise.
A Fatimid poet captured this dynamic perfectly, noting that if your tree bears the fruit of knowledge, you will bring the turning heavens beneath your hand.
That fruit ripens from a single root.
The knowledge that elevates a person above the beasts and above the turning stars themselves is received from the guides or it is never received at all.
We've watched the natural witness give its full, unyielding testimony.
From the flame that acts and gives light, to the ruby that endures the crushing pressure of fire and water, to the antidote that restores the dying soul.
The human reality is stark.
The very reason that elevates us to nature's summit can drive us to unparalleled destruction if left unmeasured.
The entire architecture of the physical world demands A pinnacle.
Every ordered thing has a summit.
The human being is nature's,
and the IMAM is humanities.
Which leaves a final question for you to mull over in your own life.
Which part of your mastery, which part of your own brilliant ungoverned reason currently runs without a guiding measure?
And what changes this week if you seek one?